in the next chapter about Taylor series
and make frequent reference to
higher-order derivatives and if you're
already comfortable with second
derivatives third derivatives and so on
great feel free to just skip ahead to
the main event now you won't hurt my
feelings but somehow I've managed not to
bring up higher-order derivatives at all
so far in this series so for the sake of
completeness I thought I'd give you this
little footnote just to go over them
very quickly I'll focus mainly on the
second derivative showing what it looks
like in the context of graphs and motion
and leave you to think about the
analogies for higher orders given some
function f of X the derivative can be
interpreted as the slope of this graph
above some point right a steep slope
means a high value for the derivative a
downward slope means a negative
derivative so the second derivative
whose notation I'll explain in just a
moment is the derivative of the
derivative meaning it tells you how that
slope is changing the way to see that at
a glance is to think about how the graph
of f of X curves at points where it
curves upwards like this the slope is
increasing and that means the second
derivative is positive
where it's curving downwards the slope
is decreasing so the second derivative
is negative
for example a graph like this one has a
very positive second derivative at the
point four since the slope is rapidly
increasing around that point whereas a
graph like this one still has a positive
second derivative at the same point but
it's smaller I mean the slope only
increases slowly at points where there's
not really any curvature the second
derivative is just zero
as far as notation goes
you could try writing it like this
indicating some small change to the
derivative function divided by some
small change to X where as always the
use of this letter D suggests that what
you really want to consider is what this
ratio approaches as DX both the X's in
this case approach zero
that's pretty awkward and clunky so the
standard is to abbreviate this as d
squared F divided by DX squared and even
though it's not terribly important for
getting an intuition for the second
derivative I think it might be worth
showing you how you can read this
notation to start off think of some
input to your function and then take two
small steps to the right each one with
the size of DX I'm choosing rather big
steps here so that we'll be able to see
what's going on but in principle keep in
the back of your mind that DX should be
rather tiny the first step causes some
change to the function which I'll call
DF 1 and the second step causes some
similar but possibly slightly different
change which I'll call DF 2 the
difference between these changes the
change and how the function changes is
what we'll call d DF you should think of
this as really small typically
proportional to the size of DX squared
so if for example you substitute it in
0.01 for DX you would expect this d DF
to be about proportional to 0.0001 and
the second derivative is the size of
this change to the change divided by the
size of DX squared or more precisely
it's whatever that ratio approaches
as DX approaches zero even though it's
not like this letter D is a variable
being multiplied by F for the sake of
more compact notation you'd write it as
d squared F divided by DX squared and
you don't typically bother with any
parentheses on the bottom maybe the most
visceral understanding of the second
derivative is that it represents
acceleration given some movement along a
line suppose you have some function that
records the distance traveled versus
time maybe its graph looks something
like this is steadily increasing over
time then it's derivative tells you
velocity at each point in time right for
example the graph might look like this
bump increasing up to some maximum and
then decreasing back to zero so the
second derivative tells you the rate of
change for the velocity which is the
acceleration at each point in time in
this example the second derivative is
positive for the first half of the
journey which indicates speeding up
that's the sensation of being pushed
back into your car seat or rather having
the car seat push you forward a negative
second derivative indicates slowing down
negative acceleration the third
derivative and this is not a joke is
called jerk so if the jerk is not zero
it means that the strength of the
acceleration itself is changing
one of the most useful things about
higher-order derivatives is how they
help us in approximating functions which
is exactly the topic of the next chapter
on Taylor series so I'll see you there
[Music]
you